I think a lot of companies are saying, well, Hey, we're already doing that.
We don't,
we don't make these decisions based on someone's race or their gender or their
age or any other protected characteristic,
but should we be doing something else? Um,
sometimes people want to throw training at it. Um,
and there's unfortunately not a lot of data that says training is very effective
and even the federal government has said that.
Hey, I'm Dave Rubin and it's small business week here on the Rubin report.
Joining me today is Wendy motor reli co-owner of HR
Northwest from Seattle Washington, Wendy, welcome to the show.
Thank you very much, Dave. So I know that legally,
I have to ask you about what life is like in Seattle right now with your
autonomous zone before we get into anything else.
Of course, of course we are outside of the autonomous zone,
but it seems to be changing by the day. Yes.
Are you hearing from people that have businesses that are in the autonomous own
or around the autonomous zone about how they can treat their employees or ask
people to come to work or are people not wanting to come to work or anything
else like that?
Yes, we have clients that are outside of,
but near the autonomous zone who are dealing with the
need to protect their employees from, from some, some,
from some of the writing that is happening.
So they are dealing with opening up late, leaving, um,
letting people leave early and otherwise allowing employees to get out so they
can board up windows and, uh, that kind of thing.
Yeah.
So I thought you'd be interesting to talk to for a couple reasons because your
business sort of deals in many ways with the business of business, how,
how do you handle these strange situations, not just, you know,
autonomous zones and protests and that sort of stuff,
but obviously COVID asking employees to come back to work when everyone hears
these mixed messages from the government and from their employers and everything
else. Uh, so I guess first, can you talk a little bit about your,
your company's sort of general ethos and then how you apply that to these
strange times that we're in right now?
Sure. Yes. Well,
what we do is we are HR professionals.
We help our clients make good business decisions with respect to
employment related matters. So we,
we try to help our clients strike that balance between taking care of
employees and doing right by them and then also doing right by the business so
that this business can continue to be sustainable and exist for a long period of
time. So, um, we help our clients navigate very tricky laws,
especially the more recent laws like the FCRA, the families,
first coronavirus response that just recently passed, um, you know,
back in late March. And there are,
there's just a tangle of complexities around that. So.
You guys learn on the fly because I know that looking at these PPE
documents and everything we signed up for,
and it from talking to other small businesses,
it's like whether you're an HR professional or a small business owner or a
lawyer, I mean, this is seriously complex stuff that often changes. I mean,
every week it seems like the rules and regulations change.
It is it's changing constantly. We,
we subscribe to a number of different alerts with the government, with, um,
with law firms and then we have some HR related resources that we buy into as
well. But then a lot of it is our team just keeping on top of it,
reading up on the regulations themselves. And,
and then we're constantly kind of, um,
discussing it with each other to make sure that we're,
we're all staying on the same page about how these should be interpreted and
utilized.
What are the types of things that businesses are going through right now?
Like some of the consistent questions that you guys are getting as businesses?
Yeah.
A huge question that keeps coming up is that my employee is scared to come to
work. They are, they are immune compromised maybe,
or they just don't want to come to work right now because they're afraid of
coronavirus or they have some other reason that they just feel really
uncomfortable coming in. So that's been the biggest challenge.
And I would say most of the time we're seeing employers giving people a leave of
absence, um,
at least for a few months while we all sort of weather the storm,
um, of course it's understandable,
but at some point businesses get to a point where they say, Hey,
this is causing serious staffing issues now. And I have to bring my people back.
Are you hearing a ton? This is a slight offshoot of the,
of the Corona thing specifically,
but are you hearing a ton from employers or employees that are now,
uh,
being confronted with all these diversity and inclusion memos and all of these
things, sort of a set of guidelines that it's,
it's always seems sort of unclear where it comes from or how they have to apply
it, uh, where suddenly, you know, just hiring someone on,
on the basis of their qualification is no longer.
Yeah, that is a really difficult question. We've had clients come to us and ask,
Hey, what should we be doing around diversity equity inclusion?
And should we be doing more? So we're,
we're definitely having that conversation.
I personally really like to look at the data and the research around it. Uh,
not just assume it's a hiring problem or it's a promotion problem,
but really try to try to dig into the details.
I think that certainly it makes sense for companies to look at whether they have
any specific biases in their hiring processes. If it's,
if that's clear that you are making these decisions based characteristics other
than their qualifications for the job,
then of course a company should absolutely look at that. Um,
but I think a lot of companies are saying, well, Hey, we'll already doing that.
We don't,
we don't make these decisions based on someone's race or their gender or their
age or any other protected characteristic,
but should we be doing something else? Um,
sometimes people want to throw training at it. Um,
and there's unfortunately not a lot of data that says training is very effective
and even the federal government has said that. Um,
so it is an area where we're still grappling.
We're talking to various diversity experts out there to try to figure out
what does, what is the right way to approach this problem? Have you seen.
The general sort of business of, uh,
HR change say over the last decade or so where now it seems like so much of
it is public where maybe back in the day, if people had a problem,
you complain to your superior, they take it to HR. There's some sort of process,
maybe it's good. Maybe it isn't versus these days where it's sort of like,
if something happens to someone at work, what's the first thing you do,
you screenshot the email yet you text it to somebody at Buzzfeed.
Next thing you know,
the boss has been fired before the company has done any sort of, uh,
research or, you know, uh, uh, an investigation.
Yes, that has added a huge new component.
So now instead of employees, maybe off of work,
having a few beers at a local bar might have a conversation together about
something work-related.
Now that conversation ends up getting broadcast and it is causing a lot,
I think a lot of harm in a lot of ways because people aren't,
aren't filtering what they're saying.
The information is getting back to their boss,
that they called their boss a jerk on social media and it's causing a lot of
issues and sometimes employees get fired and that firing is upheld when they're
all they're saying is my boss is a jerk.
And sometimes the language is a lot more colorful than that. Yeah.
That must be interesting for you that you deal with all sorts of different
companies that have different cultures,
as opposed to being just an in-house HR team that you're dealing with.
You're dealing with one boss or one culture you're dealing with all sorts of
different ones, right?
We are yes, all sorts of different businesses,
all sorts of different cultures and environments.
And so we really try to tailor what we do to that culture and environment and
get to know our clients well and understand what they're trying to do so that we
can help guide their policies and their reactions to employee questions and
concerns in that way.
So what should the average person that doesn't know anything about HR
people? What should we know about HR people?
Because I think you guys probably get caught in the mess more than anybody else
these days.
We do. I would say right now,
HR people are all just trying to keep up with of the legislation and how it
all interacts together. And we work with clients in Washington, Oregon,
and California,
which have a lot of complex state laws on top of new
brand new federal laws. And it's often very,
very unclear how they all are supposed to work together. Um, I,
I think that in general,
HR people are doing their best to navigate all of that and act as sort of that,
that intermediary between senior management and
employees. Um, and of course,
just like in any profession, there's some, some bad apples out there too.
Yeah. All right. Well now I'll let you be sales woman or sales person, uh,
pimp out your website and the bids for anyone that wants more info.
Yeah. Thank you. We, you can find out more information at our website,
which is HR T northwest.com.
It stands for human resources team and Northwest just spelled out.com.
Um, our clients are generally based in Washington and Oregon,
but many do have other locations such as in California.
And we really try to help businesses and other organizations
to make good business decisions when it comes to their employees and
try to do right by everyone.
Nice. Well,
I thank you for doing this and I know you guys have a unique set of challenges
up in the Pacific Northwest these days. So good luck with everything.
And let me know if I can help in any way.
Thank you very much. Appreciate it. If.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, check our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.